comme tous les matins réveil à 3h30
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la journée va être longue se lever tôt
dans sa fuite le sens et ça fait marcher
les drones comme le jeune michael ils
sont 70 adolescents à être ici pour en
baver
pourquoi as tu choisi de venir ici j'ai
changé mon inquiétude quel genre
d'attitude
comporter mal ce n'était pas bien
dans le dortoir voisins aux filles elles
aussi doivent être remise dans le droit
chemin
chelbi 15 ans est devenu un bon petit
soldat
la course à pied les entraînements
physiques c'est dur moi j'étais
tellement paresseuse maintenant je le
suis moi
à
discipline militaire et entraînement
physique intensif
ces ados vont vivre cinq mois un rythme
d'enfer
[Musique]
comté de palm beach en floride
bienvenue à ligueux l'académie depuis
1997 chaque année près de 160
adolescents défilent entre ses murs ils
ont entre 13 et 16 ans bon le programme
est gratuit
ce ne sont ni des criminels ni des
voyous juste des ados un peu perturbés
ou en échec scolaire
ambiance quasi carcéral un maître mot
tolérance zéro
chelbi c'est son père qui l'a forcé à
s'inscrire aujourd'hui elle encaisse
sans broncher
je suis venu ici pour améliorer ma
relation avec mon père avoir de
meilleures notes et apprendre à être
plus motivés et moins précieuses
[Musique]
les recrues sont surveillés 24 heures
sur 24 par une quarantaine
d'instructeurs militaires formés par le
shériff
[Musique]
maintenant je vérifie que tout est bien
plié
que les boutons sont bien cousu la
serviette de toilette doit être bien
rangé les hors bord du lit sans aucun
espace entre les deux
ses filles chez elles ne savent rien ne
range pas ne plie pas leurs affaires ici
on leur apprend tout ça
rien à dire shelby fait un sans faute
mais pour sa voisine c'est mal parti
son uniforme n'est pas bien repassée il
ya des faux pli
non sa chemise n'est pas bien plus
ce n'est pas bien à l'umih alors que ça
devrait lèvres son uniforme n'est pas
piller correctement ça devrait être de
la même largeur
vous voyez la différence ça c'est
correct ça ne l'est pas
a priori la différence ne saute pas aux
yeux mais alix aircal est
très méchant mais il ne comprenait pas
qu'à moi l'important c'est d'apprendre
de ses erreurs
j'espère y arriver les prochains jours
car l'expérience
[Musique]
à
l'académie aucune intimité même pour la
douche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout est chronométré une minute pour se
laver deux minutes pour s'habiller
mieux vaut respecter les consignes sinon
c'est la sanction immédiate les recrues
sont arrivées il ya maintenant quatre
mois certains ne s'y font toujours pas
[Musique]
pouvoir dormir longtemps alors le temps
de se doucher
ma famille
tout le manque
michael n'a que 13 ans c'est le plus
jeune de la promo à son arrivée il était
complètement perdue
le plus difficile c'était le premier
jour
oui
les instructeurs étaient beaucoup plus
dur avec nous et plus triplement
étoilé
à leur arrivée au camp voici comment ça
se passe
[Musique]
arrête de sourires ne me regardent plus
jamais en face tu ne me regarde pas et
waters
pourquoi tu pleures
c'est toi ton problème
la méthode est simple pression
psychologique maximal brimades et
humiliations
assis toi et regarde droit devant toi la
seule chose que tu as le droit de
regarder ces sondes aux dépens de
grenoble et celle ci c'est le merde où
sont les photos de ta mère
mais où ou sur le photo d'état mr cas ça
c'est vraiment des conneries
objectif briser ces ados et les
reconstruire commande ici pour qu'il
marque droit à leur retour chez eux
on en oublierait presque que l'académie
c'est aussi une école les recrues aux 8
heures de cours par jour
les proviennent de l'extérieur et
enseigne le programme normal dans un
silence religieux
ici on n'a aucun problème de discipline
quand ça arrive les instructeurs
militaires s'en charge tout de suite les
enfants ici sont plus concentrés parce
qu'ils savent qu'il ya des sanctions qui
leur en donner
s'il se comporte mal ils seront privés
de coups de fil ou même de visite
ici c'est très strict je peux rien faire
sans demander la permission
[Musique]
pour aller à
l'école à la baguette ça semble marcher
comme les autres chelbi a fait des
progrès avant j'avais d'aidé et des f
maintenant j'ai de bien meilleures notes
comment ça se fait comment tu expliques
ici ils te forces à aller à l'école
chez moi je séchais tout le temps les
cours et je ne faisais pas mes devoirs
à l'académie aucune distraction pas de
télé pas de jeux vidéo par la force des
choses certains ont pris goût à la
lecture
nous leur donnons les moyens d'apprendre
après c'est à eux de décider ce qu'ils
veulent en faire beaucoup reviennent
nous voir pour nous dire qu'ils n'ont
que des a et des baies beaucoup
réalisent que nous leur offrons la
chance de réussir et quand ils l'ont
compris ils n'ont pas envie de gâcher
sainte
michael lui a toujours été un bon élève
mais rien à faire la lecture c'est pas
son truc
la lecture c'est bon pour l'esprit
je veux pas gaspiller mon énergie à lire
son énergie michael préfère la consacrer
à ses pitreries
monsieur je peux passer près de la
barrière non on ne demande pas comme ça
il donne aux toilettes
je vous paierai on ne négocie pas à si
bien par ici violenté
et c'est le sergent maurice la terreur
du camp qui va s'occuper personnellement
du cas de michael
tu crois qu'on puisse n'importe où ici
tu vas pas t'en tirer comme ça avec
l'économie
continue
pour son insolence 20 minutes d'exercice
physique
nous
sommes plus haut mais ce n'est qu'un
enfant il n'a que 13 ans
sainte injustement c'est cet enfant qui
va entrer chez vous par effraction et
vous cambrioler c'est lui qui va vous
braquez avec un pistolet sur la tempe
pour voler votre voiture alors non ce
n'est pas un enfant pour vous c'est
qu'un enfant mais pour la justice
pourrait même devenir l'ennemi public
numéro 1 dans quelques années je
n'espère pas et tu spécial
tu crois être au dessus des règles ok
pourquoi tu arrives pas à suivre les
règles pour toi tu n'arrives pas obéir
j'essaie monsieur je fais du mieux
après la punition michael va continuer
d'en baver car ici tous méritent
week-end en famille coup de téléphone
courrier lui a accumulé les sanctions il
n'a pas vu sa mère depuis trois semaines
ça c'est ma mère
là c'est moi tu mon père ma belle mère
il te manque il me manque tous ils
disent que j'ai beaucoup mûri que j'ai
changé
ils disent que je les écoute et que je
les respecte plus
michael et sa famille habitent dans ce
quartier résidentiel de palm beach
sa mère robin a divorcé il ya deux ans
et s'est remarié un changement que
michael a mal vécu
cela ressemble à une crise d'ado pour
robin c'est beaucoup plus grave que cela
elle est persuadée que son fils allait
mal tourner
et rebelles
irrespectueux une manipulateur il
arrêtait pas de lever les yeux au ciel
et de faire des grimaces des petits
bruits agace on rigole mais que son
creux kings il avait un réel problème
avec l'autorité
cinq mois de traitement de choc c'était
pour elle la solution de la dernière
chance
qu'est ce que vous en pensez tél déçu
par an je suis très énervé il connaît
les règles et c'est comme partout il
doit assumer
mais il doit payer tu vois et c'est ce
qui se passe il est sanctionné pour son
mauvais comportement
vous ne pensez pas que c'est un peu trop
dur non pas du tout s'il est capable de
survivre à ça à 13 ans celui fait une
bonne expérience quand il aura 15 16 ou
18 ans il sera moins influençable et
plus fort dans
à l'académie la tension ne sera jamais
tout est fait ici pour faire regretter
aux recrues leur petit confort les
plateaux repas arrive directement de la
prison voisine
certains repas sont bons d'autres sont
mauvais mais ils doivent y faire s'ils
ont faim et ils vont devoir les manger
ça
même les repas sont une épreuve les
pensionnaires ont deux minutes pour
manger les pieds joints une main à plat
sur la cuisse et pas de couteau
là ça me plaît de manger vite
j'aime bien ça
interdiction formelle de discuter entre
eux ou même de s'adresser à un
instructeur sans autorisation
je fais ça depuis un petit bout de temps
comment tu te sens j'ai mal partout
surtout bras
si les ados échappent à la vigilance des
instructeurs militaires ils n'ont aucune
chance face aux caméras extérieures
comme intérieures la vidéo est partout à
l'exception des douches et des toilettes
chaque session il ya quelques incidents
des bagarres entre enfants nous des
plaintes alors on doit tout enregistré
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 quel
genre de quinte
les enfants qui auraient été victimes
d'abus de la part des instructeurs tout
peut arriver
à l'abri des regards de la vidéo c'est
dans les douches que les risques de
dérapage sur les plus grands c'est
souvent là que les instructeurs viennent
s'occuper des fortes têtes
retire ses vêtements mouillés et change
toi tout de suite
ce jour là le jeune fils a refusé de se
plier aux ordres
la tension monte l'adolescent résiste
les instructeurs menace de l'exclure de
l'académie mais cela ne suffit pas ils
en viennent thomas fils est immobilisé
comme lâcher la
fesci
à qui tu parles comme ça un petit gars
tu n'as pas compris c'est moi le chef
ici et toi tu n'es rien
c'est ça qu'on gère tous les fils là
vous avez vu sa vraie nature il est là
parce que ses parents ne peuvent plus le
contrôler et que lui-même ne maîtrise
pas sa colère vous avez bien vu
tu fermes ta gueule un veau méthode ne
fonctionne pas avec lui
le programme ne marche pas avec tous les
enfants avec lui on essaye mais lui il
refuse de coopérer
l'eagle academy c'est aussi une école où
l'on fait la queue devant l'infirmerie
pas pour soigner de petits bobos mais
pour venir prendre sa dose de calmants
la chimie en accompagnement des méthodes
musclées
c'est quoi ces médicaments
cdu concerta
ont certains 36 mg
il doit en prendre ces deux cachets par
jour
le concerta c'est un médicament censé
calmer les enfants considérés comme
hyperactif et les aider à se concentrer
comme michael un quart des recrues en
prend tous les jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bon vieux parcours du combattant
pousser les recrues à se dépasser
physiquement et leur donner confiance en
eux c'est un des objectifs de l'académie
avant d'arriver ici presque aucun savait
faire trop
non
quoi
le quest c'est l'épreuve physique finale
qui aura lieu dans trois jours et que
tout le monde redoute
des heures d'exercices calqué sur
l'entraînement des marines que les
recrues prépare de plus cinq mois sans
relâche
côté filles on travaille le mental
dépasser son vertige c'est le défi de
shelby comme d'habitude elle s'y plient
sans sourciller sa mission grimper à 35
mètres puis s'est lancé pour attraper un
trapèze
fitch a rappelé qu'il est bien monté
encore
[Musique]
allez vas-y tu peux y arriver
gallet
[Applaudissements]
et bien je suis fier de toi t'es content
de toi shelby oui je suis contente de
l'avoir fait et rapidement mais j'ai eu
peur
tu as eu peur de quoi mais lens et
vernon trapèze j'ai cru que j'allais
tomber c'était le plus difficile mais je
suis contente
chelbi a gagné ses cinq minutes de coup
de fil c'est pour son père à qui elle
raconte ses exploits
est monté tout là haut sur le poteau et
puis
est-ce que tu atteindras fais
presque
tu as dû avoir peur
le papa ben il est divorcé depuis dix
ans il élève seul sa fille et il vit
dans la crainte permanente qu'elle tombe
enceinte
je suis monté dans sa chambre pour
changer ça et j'étais en train de tirer
le drap derrière la tête de lit quand
j'ai remarqué quelque chose qui
ressemblait à une cicatrice sur un mois
mais je n'ai pas compris tout de suite
j'ai cru que certaines poches
alors je me suis rapproché du coin le
plus sombre
tout d'un coup 10 cm de mon visage il y
avait deux yeux qui me regardait j'ai
compris qu'il y avait un garçon planqué
derrière son lit
je lui ai demandé ce qu'il faisait là et
il m'a répondu que shelby l'avait invité
à passer la nuit
alors j'ai dit ne bouge pas et j'ai tout
de suite appelé la police
une semaine plus tard chelbi
atterrissait à l'académie un bon moyen
de la ramener dans le droit chemin et de
l'endurcir selon son père
considère pas que c'est une punition je
vois ça comme une expérience
exceptionnelle pour elle
et elle s'en sort tellement bien elle
s'épanouit
alors qu'avant elles étaient renfermés
charlie timide
c'est important qu'elle soit un leader
[Musique]
le jour j à l'académie l'examen final le
qwest a lieu dans quelques heures
pourquoi tu pries ce que je suis
vraiment angoissé à cause du quest je
veux vraiment réussir pour leur prouver
que je suis capable de faire
pour ajouter au stress les recrues
ignore tout des épreuves à venir mais
cela ne perturbe pas michael autres
mesures
il pense que je vais réussir parce que
je suis un peu fou et que j'aime
beaucoup d'énergie c'est pour ça que je
vais réussir
en oubliant ceux recueillis aussi du
côté des filles elles sont toutes plongé
dans la bible
pour la première fois chelbi montre un
signe de fragilité
tu penses que ça va être difficile oui
certainement avec tous les exercices
qu'on va devoir faire
tu as peur oui oui je suis très nerveuse
sa copine n'y a ni martinez qui est en
moins bonne condition physique que les
autres et confiante
je vais mettre un peu plus de temps je
suis capable de réussir la même chose
que les autres
il est 18 heures
l'épreuve finale commencer va durer près
de huit heures à partir de maintenant
les recrues sont entre les mains de
l'élite de l'armée américaine les forces
spéciales
au programme une série d'épreuves
physiques et psychologiques emprunté à
l'entraînement des marines tout est fait
pour tester leur endurance et tous les
moyens sont bons pour les déstabiliser
les faire abandonner
dès le début michael est pris pour cible
à quoi dans les oreilles à des bouchons
pourquoi cancervous fout le camp non
c'est parce que j'ai été opéré
pendant toute la durée de l'épreuve les
recrues seront constamment aspergé d'eau
froide
histoire de rendre les exercices encore
plus difficile
autre raffinement du sable pour les
aveugles et
on allait
[Applaudissements]
une seule bouchée de ceux en vigueur et
c'est l'élimination
ici on ne recule devant aucun moyen pour
les faire craquer
pour les filles aucun traitement de
faveur
le bac à glace c'est l'épreuve la plus
redoutée
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez qu'ils s'en prennent aux non
ils ne sont pas
mais ils sont la prochaine fois
jusque-là michael tient le choc
là maintenant meurent de froid
il est minuit la température est tombée
à 5 degrés
le froid fait ses premières victimes
premier abandon de
marque
les filles travaillent en équipe et
soutiennent la plus faible martinez on
ne prie
elle est sur le point de fatigue
why why chape qu'est ce qu'il ya arrête
de chalets ou repart là-bas décide toi
boîte
[Musique]
michael lui à bout de force abandonne
[Applaudissements]
regardez moi ce loser tu es un looser tu
veux être un perdant toute ta vie c'est
ça
non monsieur est parti pour tout lâcher
dans ta vie toi aller mais voilà
allez ça va aller t'en fais pas fait du
bon boulot
pourquoi tu as abandonné lorsque je fais
jouer
ici oui je suis déçu très déçu
c'est dieu
allez les gars réchauffer l'eau je fais
le
tu vas tu accroché à sparwood oui
monsieur
la survie
la discipline
travail en équipe on s'encourage il est
une heure du matin la seule pause repas
de l'épreuve d'une part foot et manque
de chance elles sont congelés grimpant
les recrues n'en sont plus à ça près
premièrement grand père que j'allais le
faire
alors je vais aller jusqu'au bout et je
vais réussir
c'est sympa il s'amuse bien et ça ne
fait que commencer déjà six heures
essayons d'y
c'en est trop pour martinez cette fois
ci elle jette l'épongé
tout était très bien et oui
j'ai laissé tomber mon équipe non
regarde tout ce que tu as accompli
[Musique]
il est deux heures du matin
les citations les pavés fini vous avez
réussi
15 gars sont échoués une fille seulement
a été recalé
la quille la fin de session un pique
nique est organisé à l'académie c'est la
première fois que les parents pénètrent
à l'intérieur du camp
ceux qui ont réussi le pot est ont droit
aux honneurs
jour de gloire pour shelby et son père
bill
elle a réussi je suis super content réel
aussi toute la famille est super fier
michael lui ne se remet pas de son échec
sa mère ne
suis déçu mais on en revient toujours à
la même chose il faut mais aux ordres et
l'important c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout
pour bill c'est certain sa fille a
compris la leçon désormais tout va mieux
se passer entre eux
dans les problèmes arrivent maintenant
on sait les gérer alors qu'avant on
songe à l'été le temps
grâce à ses bonnes notes chelbi va
réintégrer son ancienne école
à venir moins souriant pour michael lui
ne sait pas trop ce qui l'attend
je ne sais pas je vais peut-être revenir
ici ou retourner dans mon ancienne école
qu une autre session il ferait le plus
grand bien
pour michael ce serait encore six mois
en enfer non
ligue à l'académie a tellement de succès
qu'elle va s'agrandir et doubler ses
effectifs
quant à la promotion de michael shelby
et les autres à en croire les
statistiques 1 sur 4 rejoindra les rangs
de l'armée américaine est plus embêtant
pour l'académie un sur cinq aura affaire
à la justice
là